parce que vous êtes une femme dans 3h 37
minutes exactement vous allez travailler
gratuitement ça vous énerve ça énerve
beaucoup de femmes je pense que ça
énerve aussi les hommes en tout cas je
l'espère alors non les femmes ne
travaillent pas vraiment gratuitement à
partir d'aujourd'hui à 11h25 et 19
secondes en fait ce calcul est réalisé
chaque année par le média féministe les
glorieuse pour 2023 l'écart de salaire
entre les femmes et les hommes est de
15,4 % selon Eurostat les glorieuses
rapportent donc cet écart de salaire
européen au nombre de jours ouvrés en
France en 2023 mais ce calcul est
trompeur sur plusieurs aspects
premièrement il ne se base pas sur les
différences à postees et à temps de
travail égal or en France en 2017
l'écart en équivalent temps plein entre
les hommes et les femmes était de 5,3 %
dans le privé pour un même poste
deuxièmement les chiffres d'Eurostat
prennent uniquement en compte les
salaires des entreprises de 10 salariés
ou plus troisièmement en France 27 % des
femmes travaillent à temps partiel
contre seulement 8 % des hommes or ce
calcul ne prend pas en compte ces
différences temps partiel temps plein ce
15,4 % est donc une moyenne très
approximative ce que même les glorieuses
reconnaissent et plusieurs raisons
expliquent cet écart qui reste de trop
premièrement les femmes doivent plus
aménager leur temps de travail pour
pouvoir s'occuper de leurs enfants ou
même de personnes âgées sans oublier
leur congé maternité et deuxièmement les
secteurs les plus rémunérateurs sont
souvent des métiers dit masculin les
femmes travaillent plus dans la santé et
l'action sociale les hommes plutôt dans
la construction ou encore le transport